paul un message de l' agence régionale
de santé du réseau addiction martinique
et du réseau de santé périnatale matnik
[Musique]
et pendant tout cela et pendant tout
cela les autres formations politiques de
martinique se met en ordre de marche car
des échéances arrivent vont très vite
les européens et municipal a traité m
il faut donc poursuivre la structuration
c'est le cas chez les socialistes avec
la fédération socialiste de martinique
bonjour béatrice men et la première
secrétaire fédérale dans son caddie les
socialistes de martinique ne se font pas
trop entendre car l'heure est davantage
à la réflexion à l'organisation non le
temps de parole a été on va dire feutrée
puisque nous étions pendant une période
de grandes vacances
mais malgré ça nous avons eu à
travailler
nous avons eu aussi à sortir et à faire
quelques actions je crois que le temps
de la structuration c'est un temps long
également il y à des nécessités
lorsqu'on est dans une association c'est
nécessité ont été comblés et aujourd'hui
c'est l'heure en effet d'un travail plus
politique plus sociale
bref le travail d'un parti nous avait
été élu à la tête de la fédération
socialiste en mars dernier et béatrice
faible des deux parties où le nombre de
militants appelés à voter à l'époque
avec un cotisation à jour était de 138
savez semblait fort bas la tendance
s'inverse hôtel la tendance oui
s'inverse
légèrement mais j'ai je tire un peu la
sonnette d'alarmé vous savez le monde
militants qu'ils soient associatifs
qu'ils soient politiques subit quand
même une certaine crise il faut là il
faut l'avouer non pas que nous ayons pas
nous n'ayons pas de sympathisants
puisqu'il y a énormément de personnes
qui sollicitent de travailler avec nous
mais c'est vrai que le militantisme et
l'engagement sont en berne et d'ailleurs
je salue le monde associatif
parce qu'il est encore très courageux de
militer c'est à militer c'est un acte
gratuit
c'est du bénévolat et pour ce qui
concerne les parkings bien sûr j'ai
encore du bénévolat parce qu on est
découragés parce qu'on est désabusé
peut-être je pense qu'il ne faut pas
céder en tout cas à cette tentation
d'être désabusés ou de ne croire en rien
au contraire
par contre il faut être persuadé que
l'on peut chacun a amené sa pierre à
l'édifice à une réflexion qu'elles
soient politiques qu'elles soient
sociales à une action qu'elle soit
associatives ou sportives il y aura
certainement vous allez le confirmer une
université des manches et des
socialistes comme ce fut le cas ces
dernières années
nous allons essayer en effet de
concrétiser cet événement sur lequel
auquel nous sommes en tout cas très
attaché et qui portera forcément sur des
thèmes qui concernent la vie quotidienne
des martiniquais ça ne sera pas une
grand messe mais bien un événement où
tous les martiniquais d'ailleurs seront
invités et tous seront invités
d'ailleurs à venir parler de leurs
préoccupations et le projet pour la
martinique selon l'afe le fsm
le projet il est grand si je pouvais
vous vous en parlait en cinq minutes ça
serait bien triste mais je crois que là
là aujourd'hui la colonne vertébrale de
l'action politique en tout cas du projet
que nous envisageons rappelons quand
même que nous appartenons parti
socialiste écologie
nous avons et moi je pense que sur le
territoire martiniquais
cette nécessité se fait de plus en plus
prégnante nous avons ce devoir ce besoin
cette nécessité cette urgence de mettre
au coeur des préoccupations de politique
publique le développement soutenable
guy durable l'écologie la transition
énergétique
c'est une urgence aujourd'hui c'est plus
une urgence d'un temps long c'est une
urgence d'un encours voilà béatrice
table et pas mal pendant les grandes
vacances il ya eu cette pétition pour
que les martiniquais puisse se faire
dépister gratuitement concernant le taux
de chlordécone dans l'organisme humain
c'est une pétition qui a fait son chemin
convient de signataires oui elle a fait
son chemin on n'est pas loin des 5000
signatures alors on en est satisfait
mais qu'est-ce qu'on en fait non c'est
pas c'est pas qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
déjà on remarque quand même un intérêt
et on précise que l'intérêt n'est
peut-être pas d'ailleurs suffisant alors
il faut quand même ajouté qu'il ne
s'agissait pas simplement de solliciter
la gratuité du test de chlordécone parce
que nous avons quand même besoin pour
mettre en place une politique publique
de savoir à quel niveau les martiniquais
les guadeloupéens sont intoxiqués par
cette molécule et d'autres d'ailleurs
mais il s'agit aussi de solliciter de la
part du ministère de la santé des
solidarités la mise en place d'une
véritable politique de suivi médical
pour les martiniquais et l'ouverture
d'une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
parce qu'à un moment tout de même en
martinique faut qu'on apprenne à montrer
et à pointer du doigt les
responsabilités
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'au
niveau du ministère que les lignes
bougent un peu et c'est encore ce que je
vous dis c'est à dire que pour que on
exige souvent beaucoup de nos élus mais
comme on dit chez nous faut que nos
vaillants pâle bail en palce est aussi
signé cette pétition pour dire pour que
demain des débuts qui vont s'asseoir
devant
un ministre puisse dire voilà nous avons
150 mille signatures pour ce
manifestation nous pour pour en tout cas
ce sujet nous avons des manifestations
qui sont organisées nous avons des
associations qui se mettent en oeuvre
nous avons un besoin
l'urgence commence à se faire jour il y
à une pression de la population fait
quelque chose donnez nous des surfaces
de ministre ça veut dire que vous
adresser directement aux parlementaires
qui devront relayer le meilleur mais qui
d'autre que nous élus pas de relayer les
actions là est ce que vous avez eu des
appels de ses élus pour vous dire nous
vous soutenons
non mais c'est pas c'est pas dans ce
sens là que ça va nous pouvons aussi
leur dire nous vous soutenons messieurs
et mesdames les élus verts d'accord il y
aura des échéances qui arrivent vont
très vite béatrice délai les européennes
ce sera dans quelques mois des élections
européennes du 26 mai 2019 afin d'élire
les soixante-dix-neuf députés européens
représentant la force au parlement
l'oublier ça veut dire que vous êtes
déjà dans une logique de discussion avec
le avec les instances nationales du
parti socialiste avec des collègues de
la guadeloupe les collègues de la guyane
pour savoir qui nous pourrions mettre en
situation éligible
oui alors il ya comme vous le savez une
disparition de la circonscription d
outre-mer des ultramarins d'ailleurs
même pas des autres versé des
ultramarins aujourd'hui oui la
négociation a commencé parce que c'est
une négociation
d'autres territoires disent vouloir être
représentés donc il faut que nous nous
nous affichons notre particularité puis
notre volonté de participer à ce débat
européen qui est très important parce
que souvent les les citoyens se
désintéressent énormément de ce sujet
pour autant lorsque l'on parle par
exemple de chlordécone
on parle d'europe parce que la limite
par exemple autorisé de résidus de
chlordécone dans notre alimentation
c'est l'europe qui la fit je me dis
qu'on ne doit pas faire la france fait
et les martiniquais des antilles à son
propre réseau des noms alors non non
l'europe n'a pas dit qu'on devrait pas
faire l'europe a voté un seuil
la france a corroboré ce seuil peut être
aurait pu aller de façon plus favorable
aux populations et je vous rappelle
quand même qu'aujourd'hui le constat est
fait notamment encore aujourd'hui par la
cour des comptes européenne la
commission de la cour des comptes
européenne qui dit que les états
européens ne préserve pas suffisamment
leur population des effets du climat
mais les effets du crime a engendré
aussi des problèmes de santé
environnementale et de tous les effets
et là sont nés une preuve dira des
populations parce qu'on parle du
chlordécone mignan n'a d'autre il ya le
glyphosate qui vient d'être prolongé
bon donc d'utilisation de vient d'être
prolongée il devient inadmissible de
tolérer que politiquement on admettre
que des populations que des êtres
humains soient plus ou moins empoisonné
c'est inadmissible c'est même on se
demande comment encore aujourd'hui les
populations font pour tolérer qu'on leur
dise oui on vous empoisonne un peu mais
que la révolte de la population
oui non j'avais déjà couru oui oui
j'appelle à une vraie mobilisation tout
à fait j'appelle j'appelle à une prise
de conscience
j'appelle à une mobilisation des
martiniquais singulièrement
contrairement à d'autres nous ne vivons
pas sur un continent nous n'avons qu'une
seule île dont nous n'avons pour
beaucoup pas envie de partir qui subit
les effets aujourd'hui des changements
climatiques qui est un territoire à
risque c'est un niveau 5 de risque à la
martinique un risque de submersion
risque cyclonique risque volcanique
risque sismique et j'en passe bon alors
si nous ne comprenons pas en plus
que si l'action humaine vient encore
ajouté de façon très prégnante et
quotidienne par l'utilisation de
pesticides par l'utilisation abusive par
exemple de l'autosolisme c'est à dire le
fait d'être seul dans des voitures alors
que des politiques notamment de mobilité
sont mises en place et participe de la
baisse de la pollution de la pollution
chez nous si les martiniquais ne
prennent pas conscience de ça et ne
prennent pas conscience qu'on en meure
déjà on n'en mourra pas demain on en
meurt déjà et on a des enfants malades
c'est à cause de ça emmanuel macron qui
dévisse dans les cotes de popularité qui
est taxé de tout déconstruire au niveau
social vous tenterez d'entrer dans cette
brèche
ramené au plan local cela donnerait quoi
selon vous quelle est votre vision de la
politique gouvernementale au niveau
social martinique où il n'ya pas de
brèche il ya aujourd'hui un gouvernement
de droite qui n'a rien ay d'humaniste ni
de social
c'est un piège d'ailleurs ça a été un
piège infâmes que de dire on peut être
de gauche et de droite c'est faux il ya
une gauche il ya une droite dans
l'action on peut avoir des élus de
droite qui sont pourtant très sociaux
mais lorsque l'on parle de partie 2-2 et
d'idéologie il ya bien une idéologie de
droite est une idéologie de gauche
aujourd'hui on arrive à une idéologie
qui est une idéologie ultralibérale qui
met chez nous en difficulté des gens
parce que on en parle peut être pas
suffisamment
lorsque vous dites aux retraités en
martinique qu' il ya une augmentation de
la csg sur leur leur pension de retraite
mais que par ailleurs vous décidez avec
la cherté de la vie en martinique et
l'inflation que nous connaissons que
leur pension de retraite n'est plus
indexée sur l'inflation
vous ne mettez pas seulement en cause
vous ne mettez pas seulement difficulté
le retraité vous mettez le retraitant
difficulté est probablement son enfant
qu'il héberge toujours voir son petit
enfant parce que on le sait la
population martiniquaise
vieillissante mais au-delà de ça la
population martiniquaise subit un
chômage très important ce jeu me sur ce
bon sens chez les jeunes 60% vous croyez
que les jeunes vont ou et son ou
lorsqu'elles 60% sont chômeurs et
peut-être car entre 25 et 40% chez leurs
parents bairi chez les grands parents
qui eux ont un toit à leur proposer
merci béatrice dalle et d'avoir été avec
nous rappelle que vous êtes la première
secrétaire fédérale des socialistes en
martinique bonne journée merci de votre
invitation au revoir bonne journée à
tous et je vous donne déjà le rendez
vous